in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Keith
and Kathy are with us hey guys how are
ya hey Dave hey Dave we're doing good
welcome welcome where do you guys live
we live just outside Austin Texas
welcome to Nashville good to have you so
you're here to do your debt-free scream
yes we are finally you're finally here
how much of you paid off
we paid off thirty thousand in the last
18 months way to go making what kind of
money 77 to 89 cool what do you guys do
for a living I'm an engineer and I do
this you do this this being the four
kids standing in front of you what are
their names and ages
we got Sidney who's 10 Timothy who's 8
Jordan who is now 7 and Alex who's 9
right down the line there we got the
perfect I love it congratulations so
what kind of debt was the 30,000 well we
finished our paint off her house that
was the last push why can we say finally
paying off our house Wow so 18 months is
not the whole story then tell me the
story that means well we we found you
early like I think 2003 and we is right
before I got pregnant with her we got
through the steps really quick we didn't
have a lot of debt maybe 5,000 knock
that out got emergency fun had another
kid had another kid another kid right
and then right before this one that our
last one was born we had just a lot of
life happened like for six years it was
on top of our fourth kid in less than
four years we had a real hard personal
situation happened that kind of took the
wind out of our sails and we had tons of
medical six surgeries mom out of
capacity for a year Wow he had a layoff
for six months no severance so we had
just a lot of life and we were kind of
really you know it was just hard to kind
of get by and then we met a new group of
friends and they started asking us a lot
about Ramsey and we thought well even
though we're following their principles
we just need to kind of pick ourselves
up and get this thing done and that's
what happened okay all right well you
you thank goodness when you hit that
rough rough patch
you were dead for except the house
absolutely we didn't over buy either
some yeah and that kept you under
control and because you'd be in a real
mess digging out right now if it hadn't
been for that exactly so then when you
get past the rough patch you just get
reinvigorated and go ahead and knock out
the house that's pretty much it
absolutely I didn't know he had been
throwing some extra money from a raise
to it and last September he came to me
he said you know we can get this done by
December maybe January of 2016 and I was
like okay and so with the encouragement
from our small group a small group we we
got it done so what's your home worth
now it's about 210 and your house is
paid for and it's done how weird it is
so weird I feel great it felt fantastic
thank you okay after all you guys have
been through you don't know a dime in
the world no no it's got to be a piece
that goes with that that's the big thing
the financial piece is is amazing and
that's I love telling people about it so
thank you Dave well thank you guys you
did it I didn't do it you're the hero
you're the hero I just showed you how
and listen to you every day you pushed
me I made you believe you could do it
and then you went and do it did it
that's that's how this works well
congratulations you guys so so what
obviously the rough patch is there and
the other processes you go through and
you just persevered or you kind of took
a little time off and didn't go into the
hole but didn't really making progress
for a while and then come back and
attack it what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is now that
you've been on this journey staying on a
budget that's whether you're completely
capturing every dime or just staying
within your means and that's that's the
big one to staying staying in within
that parameter that we know you stayed
within your means but you probably
didn't do a good job of the written
budget during some of those rough
patches there but we just didn't capture
the extra okay we spin it like yes we
spin it on convenience you Medicaid
medicated yeah eating out more all that
kind of stuff you just did it so we
weren't able to keep it all together to
really
okay go forward it makes sense and then
all of a sudden then when you start to
kind of feel whole again
so to speak you can turn then you can
turn up the heat again because you've
got all the tools in front of you
exactly exactly it was good to have that
margin so I'll never regret we regret in
some ways that we what am I trying to
say that we we could have done it sooner
maybe four years earlier but we had a
lot going on and thank God we had the
margin financially to not be stressed
about finances during that time but the
one thing we don't regret is that they
will remember this day and I just can't
regret that no I wouldn't know they're
here and this is this is family tree
changing stuff right here absolutely
have they been practicing from Austin
Texas they're dead free scream yes okay
they're the reason we're here okay so
you would have just done the phone call
you got to make a trip and we have to
make it we have to make a memory out of
this and so we're gonna meet Dave going
to Dave's office eating some of
Dorothy's cookies we're gonna do the
full-on experience exactly very cool I'm
proud of you guys congratulations
you ought to feel very weird because you
are yes in a good way in a good way
congratulations and you think the kids
really understand where you are yes they
see it every month since they were
little when we still owed over $80,000
we have a sheet and each square it was
$100 and they've colored in those
squares ever since over 80,000 so after
we went and did the final wire had our
party at her house that night they
colored in those last 18 squares they
even paid for the last square and they
were part of it very cool
that's fun I like that neat very cool
all right Keith and Kathy and the team
$30,000 paid off in 18 months that's
house and everything making 77 to eighty
nine thousand counted down let's hear a
debt free scream you guys here we go
three two one
congratulations you guys congratulations
very very very well done